En el último vídeo nos dimos cuenta
que 3 elevado a la potencia -2,
es exactamente lo mismo que
1 entre 3 elevado al cuadrado,
que por cierto,
esto es lo mismo que 1 entre 9, de lujo,
3 elevado a la -2 es igual a 1 entre 3 al cuadrado,
que es igual a 1 entre 9
y para esto
utilizamos una propiedad,
una  propiedad que conocemos muy bien
de las leyes de los exponentes, que nos dicen
que si nosotros tenemos una base,
elevada a una potencia
y a esto lo multiplicamos por la misma base
elevada a otra potencia,
entonces la base se conserva
y las potencias se suman,
y justo en este vídeo, lo que quiero trabajar,
es ver a qué es equivalente la expresión,
"a" elevado a la -"b".
Tras lo que voy es tras saber
¿a qué es equivalente esta expresión?
Quiero saber a qué es equivalente esta expresión,
y para encontrar la expresión equivalente a ésta,
voy a utilizar justo la misma propiedad,
la misma propiedad que decía "a"
y vamos a ponerla por aquí,
que "a" elevado a la "b"...
elevado a la "b",
esto a su vez lo multiplicamos por "a"...
por "a" elevado...
y bueno en este caso voy a utilizar -"b",
elevado a la -"b",
esto es exactamente lo mismo
que "a"... que "a",
elevado a la suma de estas 2 potencias
¿Estás de acuerdo?.
Elevado a la "b" más...
déjame poner otro color,
más -"b"... más -"b",
que por cierto,
esto es exactamente lo mismo que "a"...
date cuenta que la "a" se conserva,
"a" elevado a la "b" más - "b",
lo cual es "b" menos "b" y esto es 0.
Esto es 0 y entonces "a" elevado a la 0...
esto,
por otra propiedad que nosotros nos sabemos muy bien, de las leyes los exponentes,
esto es exactamente igual
a 1...
a 1, si "a" no es 0,
para toda "a" que sea distinta de 0
para
"a" distinta de 0.
Ok.
Y bueno esto lo estoy poniendo así,
porque ahora puedo concluir
cuál es la expresión equivalente a "a"
elevado a la -"b".
De aquí si yo utilizo esta parte de aquí,
me va a quedar...
lo voy a copiar y lo voy a pegar...
me va a quedar
que "a" elevado a la "b",
por "a" elevado a la -"b",
esto es exactamente lo mismo
que 1...
y ahora si divido todo entre "a" a la "b",
entre "a" elevado a la potencia "b",
de aquí voy a obtener que "a" elevado a la -"b"...
elevado a la -"b",
que es justo lo que yo quería,
esto va a ser igual a 1...
a 1...
dividido...
dividido a su vez
entre "a" elevado a la "b"...
entre  "a" elevado a la "b"
y esto para toda "a" que sea distinta de 0.
¡Está de lujo!
Ya tengo la expresión que yo quería.
Esta expresión de aquí va a ser mi expresión equivalente para "a" elevado a la -"b".
Ahora quiero que te des cuenta que éste de aquí,
éste de aquí es el inverso multiplicativo de "a" a la b,
porque cuando yo multiplico estas 2 expresiones,
me da igual a 1,
por ejemplo aquí, 1/9
es el inverso multiplicativo de 9,
que por cierto es 3 elevado al cuadrado,
y también está genial.
Acabamos de ver un caso particular
pero justo en este momento,
acabamos de decir que para un caso general,
se cumple esto,
acabamos de llegar a esta conclusión
que es bastante importante.
Ya podemos ver que cualquier base elevada
a una potencia negativa,
es exactamente lo mismo que 1
entre la misma base elevada a la misma potencia,
solamente que con signo positivo.
Y bueno, yo te había dejado de tarea que pensarás
un poco acerca de qué representaba
esta "a" elevada a la -"b"
y algunas propiedades de esta misma expresión,
¿Por qué?
Porque ahorita las vamos a utilizar
y vamos a hacer un ejemplo.
Para esto voy a poner aquí...
no sé, se me ocurre 5... no espera.
quiero cambiar de color,
vamos a utilizar otros colores que no he utilizado
como...
no, no, no, no, no ...quiero cambiar de color,
utilizando otros colores que no he utilizado.
Y ahora pongamos esto, si tengo 5...
5 elevado al cubo,
bueno nosotros sabemos cuánto es esto,
esto es exactamente lo mismo que 5 por 5, por 5
lo cual es 125.
Nosotros sabemos que 5 elevado al cubo es 125,
que por cierto, es un número bastante grande
o considerablemente grande.
Puedo decir así,
ahora si nosotros pensamos en 5 elevado a la -3...
a la -3, ¿cuánto es esto?
Bueno nosotros ya sabemos que podemos encontrar una expresión equivalente
utilizando esta igualdad de aquí,
es decir, que esto es exactamente lo mismo...
es exactamente lo mismo
que 1... que 1
entre... entre 5 elevado al cubo...
entre 5 elevado al cubo...
elevado al cubo, que por cierto,
esto es exactamente lo mismo que
1 entre 5 elevado al cubo que es 125.
Ahora quiero que te des cuenta de
dos cosas muy importantes,
1 entre 125 es el recíproco
o el inverso multiplicativo de 125
es decir, que 5 elevado al cubo es el recíproco
o el inverso multiplicativo de 5 elevado a la - 3,
y la segunda cosa que quiero que veas
es que 125 dijimos que era un número considerablemente grande,
mientras que 1 entre 125 es un número muy pequeño.
¡Ojo! Cuando elevamos a una potencia negativa, obtenemos un resultado positivo.
Sin embargo obtenemos un valor con una magnitud distinta a la original y considerablemente distinta,
pero bueno aquí tenemos un ejemplo,
yo quiero hacer 2 ejemplos más en este vídeo,
porque me gusta mucho pensar acerca de todo esto.
Así que para esto,
¿qué te parece si borramos la pantalla
para hacer otro ejemplo más?
Entonces déjenme borrar la pantalla
y quiero que trabajemos con el siguiente ejemplo.
¿Qué pasa si yo tengo
-1/2... -1/2
esto elevado a la tercer potencia...
a la tercer potencia?
Bueno pues esto es exactamente lo mismo
que -1/2 por -1/2...
-1/2 por -1/2 por -1/2,
es decir 3 veces lo mismo,
¡Oh! -1/2...
-1/2, es decir 3 veces lo mismo.
Lo cual por cierto es,
menos por menos más, por menos, menos
1 por 1, por 1 es 1
y 2 por 2, por 2 es 8,
es -1/8
es decir, que si yo me tomo -1/2 elevado al cubo
obtengo -1/8,
lo cual es un número negativo,
pero 1/8 es más pequeño que 1/2.
Ahora ¿qué va a pasar si yo me tomo este mismo -1/2? Pero ahora lo voy a elevar a una potencia negativa,
vamos a elevarlo a la -3
¿Qué voy a obtener de esto?
Bueno pues esto es lo mismo
y utilizando lo que acabamos de aprender en este vídeo, recuerda que lo que tenemos que hacer es poner un 1...
un 1,
y a esto lo voy a dividir entre
esta misma expresión, solamente que
elevado a una potencia positiva, es decir,
1 entre -1/2
elevado al cubo...
al cubo... al cubo...
y por cierto nosotros ya sabemos cuánto es
-1/2 elevado al cubo,
es justo lo que tenemos acá arriba,
por lo tanto, esta expresión que tengo aquí,
esto que está acá abajo,
acabamos de concluir hace ratito que era -1/8,
entonces, esto de aquí va a ser igual a 1...
a 1 entre -1/8...
entre a -1/8
que por cierto, nosotros sabemos que esto es exactamente lo mismo que 1.
Este 1 se conserva
y a esto en lugar de dividirlo entre una fracción
lo voy a multiplicar por el recíproco de esta fracción.
Nosotros hemos hecho divisiones
de fracciones muchas veces,
vamos a multiplicarlo por menos y el recíproco de 1 entre 8
es decir, el inverso multiplicativo es 8 entre 1
Ok, esto ya lo sabíamos,
que por cierto esto es exactamente lo mismo
que tener,
menos por más es menos
8 por 1 es 8,
y dividido entre 1 es 8,
-8,
pero, lo que sí quiero enfatizar mucho en este vídeo,
es que el resultado de elevar a una potencia negativa
no está cambiando el signo del resultado.
Date cuenta que aquí empezamos con una potencia positiva y obtuvimos aquí un valor negativo.
Mientras que aquí empezamos
con una potencia negativa
y obtuvimos también un resultado negativo,
lo que está cambiando realmente
no es el signo de nuestro resultado,
sino la magnitud de éste.